lieutenant colonel dan richelle is the
nato battle group commander on the
ground in latvia it's his job to help
deter a russian invasion here and be
prepared if vladimir putin attacks our
mission here is focused on deterrence
and a defensive capability
we do a lot of training in order to be
ready and this battle group already has
a very high state of readiness
to be able to go from a training posture
to an operational posture
very quickly a necessity given these
troops would be the first canadians to
fight we train primarily for a defensive
scenario
where
there could be an escalation of tension
where we may have to ramp up deterrence
activities all the way up to actually
defending the territorial integrity of
latvia there is a renewed meaning and
urgency to this exercise canadians are
practicing tactics aimed at a superpower
with superior firepower one part of an
institution-wide shift after years of
focusing on counter-insurgency and
roadside bombs
here the focus is on fighter jets
artillery tanks and missiles
a change in tactics to cyber defenses
and concealing equipment smaller mobile
headquarters just two vehicles back
together with a tarp
while training for the worst canada's
task force commander doesn't want to
exaggerate the threat i'm not worried
that we're going to have to deal with
innovation in the short term despite
russia's aggression in ukraine the
colonel says nato troops are effective
and so is deterrence vladimir putin
knows the consequences of attacking a
nato country i wouldn't say that
veterans is not working against russia
you know the the ukrainian crisis is one
thing
he has not attacked the nato country for
troops on the ground here they want
canadians to know one thing they're
ready and they're doing their best i
just want to reassure canadians that
their soldiers are always constantly
working hard
and we're vigilant and we're
doing our best to represent canada on
the world stage now it just becomes that
much more important that we we maintain
that focus
and that we get ready for whatever we
might have to face mercedes stephenson
global news riga